manger des patates pilées vous rappelle
sans doute de savoureux souvenirs
d'enfance la journaliste et blogueuse
marie-eve laporte revisite avec nous la
classique purée ya rien de plus comme
cette foule qui se trouve bande de terre
beurre lait ça part bien une purée mais
sa réussite vient en grande partie de la
patate elle même je trouve qu'à la
meilleure c'est vraiment la patate jaune
elle est plus dense que les autres elle
est très crémeuse qu'elle est un petit
peu goodbye on peut aussi prendre la
recette la recette un peu plus d'amidon
mais je trouve que ça donne des moins
bons résultats
ok c'est réglé on sait qu'elle peut être
choisi j'ai les pelles jeu les copains
sont deux ou en quatre selon la grosseur
on veut pas d'être aux petits cubes de
pâtes ap y'en a qu'une seule et garder
un tiers mais moi je trouve que mais
incident c'est très lent puis deux ça
peut cuire de manière plus inégal quand
c'est des gros morceaux patat
comme pour tous les légumes racines ont
par la cuisson à l'eau froide
faut pas trop les cuirs faut pas qu'ils
soient des jeunes des faits dans un
chaudron pour enlever le risque du mist
et gilles herman en chaudron à feu doux
et on s'assure que sable odorants
mélange me sentais juste évacue la
conversation publicité là on va partout
avec un réseau de toques et sec
on pile avec du beurre tempéré pour
éviter un choc thermique
et pour bien crémeux les pommes de terre
en ce temps pas acheté normalement du
lait ou de la crème peut-être pour les
jours de faim après ça il ya la
technique qu'ils lisent outil qu'est ce
que vous préférez mais ça départ pour la
patate gens une fois qu'ils avaient
tellement crémant se passe des faits
tellement bien que le bon vieux plan va
derniers résultats support parfait pour
moi cette je trouve que ça laisse quand
même un peu plus des grumes donkey kong
et des hourras s'achever la passe à la
machine comment patata en règle tout
comme un espèce de presse a aimé en
faire la plus grosse
il ya des gens qui aiment seule fin avec
une mixette où le batteur sur ce c'est
un bon moyen que ça soit lisse mais pour
vraiment faire attention parce que je
donne cinq secondes un trouble ça va
devenir la toile une fois qu'on a fait
de la colle
est-ce que c'est récupérable non non
c'est simple si l'on ne trouve
développer la nuit dans des abris
publics pas de retour possible
ouais maintenant qu'on sait bien la pile
et marie-ève à nous convaincre de
l'utiliser autrement que dans notre
fameux pâté chinois comme ce plat
surprenant de patates pilées au four oui
oui c'est un peu à produire une patate
aux photos diaries mais avec ta pomme de
tapis néons blafards font notre fromage
on fait ça ça dans un club service au
milieu de la tam et non pas dans
l'assiette
attention cette version pas très vite
il y en aura c'est tout simple c'est
d'ajouter oignons caramélisés tout
simple mais ô combien savoureux se pare
balles
[Musique]
si vous avez l'habitude de mélanger
carottes et navets dans la purée essayer
le chou fleur sur premier bon c'est pas
tout à fait et légumes et les fleurs
aussi peu faim on pourrait vraiment un
crime donc chou fleur et chèvres
[Musique]
si jamais on a un surplus de pommes de
terre on ne jette pas la dernière
accepte c'est encore qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire avec un geste en patates
pilées moi j'ai déjà en allemagne la
botte en ligne qui osent que la cuisine
de rue on vendait des petites galettes
de pommes de terre avec des oignons tous
s'étaient servis avec la compote de
pommes etc un petit peu de cannelle
safran le mari à la friteuse noël je
suis très intrigué vois ça s'appelle en
allemagne cards off et pouf et
cartophile pou faire et ça l'est
[Musique]
vraiment on voit quand même dossier
multiples possibilités apprécié c'est
juste notre imagination il ya conflit
n'est pas ce qu'on peut faire avec la
patate est bien plus raison d'avoir peur
on ouvre le frigo on sort le presse
purée et gogo au new deal est où la
crème enfin vers ta crème sûre j'ai déjà
mis la mayonnaise
étonnamment ce cas liés aux risques à
celles atteintes partir du moment où
quelque chose de bon on a quelque chose
de tellement ça va être bon pour son
poteau
[Musique]